damn reject nation i'm greg album John
Humphrey that's better so much better
than yours are going to watch the
terminator dark fate official teaser I
have had high hopes for this movie since
I saw it I think it was the Hollywood
Reporter interview with Tim Miller and
James Cameron's like a 45-minute
interview that came out a long time ago
everyone has all this faith in it now
after CinemaCon footage I've always had
faith in it and I'm sure this footage
will only solidify that faith Terminator
2 is one of my favorite movies of all
time it's probably it's usually the
matrix of Terminator 2 I flip-flopped
between which one's my favorite anyway
guys before we go into this I want to
thank everyone who's downloaded and
follow us on the Stardust app over there
with you thirty second reaction reviews
or any film TV show and/or trailer we
post daily sometimes they're micro
sketches completely free to download
completely free to use if you want to
get our opinion first before even our
YouTube video comes out go ahead and do
that today link in the description box
up in comment let's get into this about
45 seconds till premieres and there's
already 67 dislikes talking about
prejudgment yeah those people have just
great in three judgement of day
[Music]
you terminate
[Music]
haha
[Music]
oh that were you about to learn some
stuff almost
[Music]
because I was
slightly confused
[Music]
now do we win we win but keeping your
life
I love that song on this trailer bad all
right that was cool that's cool and they
said it was an official trailer at the
beginning but the title said teaser
trailer than a YouTube video and this
film or like a teaser trailer to me yeah
just tone I really like the effects
you're especially that multiplier
Terminator oh yeah a Luna the way it
looks like liquid but also very
structural and very mechanical and a
whole different way from like the t1000
I remember Tim Miller and James Cameron
saying that they really had definitive
rules on how they want their AI to work
in this movie and not just to have
something where you get to act 3 then I
could just do whatever it's all powered
yeah yeah yeah they want to have
specific rules and it looks like there's
some similarities I could see between
this in the first couple Terminator
films already you know you got a
protector Terminator or play by
Mackenzie Davis it looks like she's
protecting Natalia Reyes yes there
Connor is kind of thrown into this work
but then they have you know the the evil
Terminator hunting them down so it does
harken back more to like Terminator
wanted to I'm really excited for Sarah
Connor to return I saw this on Collider
movie talked that I feel that Sarah
Connor is kind of the Forgotten heart of
the franchise 100% people have sort of
been shifting the direction towards it's
John Connor all these different John
Connors I'm like what if you look at
terminator 1 Terminator 2 the two great
months out of this franchise Sarah
Connor is the heart of this franchise oh
yeah when you forget that as many cool
elements as there are interminable G's
that grow so too does her character grow
from the first movie to the second
continuing that here like I'm very
excited one I want to see what they do
differently of how do they define her
for today's time yeah the posters say
that this takes place the day after
Judgment Day and I think some people are
still confused I know some people are
confused we would watch this on premiere
and when it was premiering and you can
see the live chat a lot of people don't
realize that this is supposed to cancel
out all the ones I came after Terminator
2 and this is supposed to be the
official Terminator 3 that's why it's a
big deal that James Cameron's returning
for this a couple of the writers one of
the writers worked on Dark Angel will
James Cameron
another one retreated and wrote the
Sarah Connor Chronicles so it just seems
like everyone involved has a lot of
passion for this so I'm very excited to
see what they bring together there's
some stuff that looks a little too big
for my taste right now so I feel like
some people are gonna really like that
plain sequence for me I'm a little bit
split Tim Miller constantly talked about
his love for terminator 2 to me and I'm
thinking is that they're gonna be their
equivalent of the highway chase at
Terminator 2 but this time it's plain
like those blades fighting each other
and going after each other it's a little
it was a pretty freakin crazy it was
really heightened I do agree because
while the Terminator films especially
the early ones are effects Laden for
sure they are grounded to a degree where
the at least the physics make some kind
of sense and so yeah like I do worry for
a movie like this if a plane scene looks
like that might get too big or too you
know spectacle oriented and you know
kind of forget but at the same time I
just have faith in the team that's
assembling this so I'm hoping that
that's just a dazzling harrowing visual
sequence
yeah McKenzie Davis's character kind of
reminds me of the Sam Worthington
character from salvation and I couldn't
help but wonder if that's gonna be one
of those like no I wish I didn't know
that going in kind of things because
like every Terminator trailer has one
detail that they didn't need to spoil
for you I don't think so it seems like
he's established very early on in the
movie yes that's when the pipe comes at
her and she's like seems to know to
block and it knows what to do he seems
that those heightened reflexes yeah yeah
or maybe she is as opposed to like you
know someone who forgot who they are and
then they realize her a terminator
perhaps they had some type of operation
done and they did this to her like she
was formerly a human beforehand it also
I'm getting some slight Blade Runner
2049 vibes it makes sense because
Mackenzie Davis isn't that movie - now
beyond that it's it's more like the
Arnold presents thing yeah like they
show up at as far whatever like that
what I was wondering too if that's work
just he is living and he's you know
adapted to the point that he can
appreciate life in the woods or if like
Sarah Connor has been sort of a recluse
- if this is sort of Laurie Strode
situation where she's got her like dr.
house where she's just like ready in
case anything happens and then she
kind of hears about this new hope for
salvation or whatever you know he can't
be the Terminator from Terminator 2
though I went into a there's some kind
of other time-travel trim they pull but
I'm really curious I mean you know he
seems to have aged they did from what I
remember Jim Cameron saying was a calm
Jim he's my buddy and I remember James
Cameron saying is that he is a
terminator I did that you know
terminators they age that it's
established in the first one and they
were saying they want to embrace
Arnold's age now as well as Sarah
Connors age so I'm sure he's a
terminator I don't think people would
like it if he's not a terminator
I'm just curious now he the lifestyle
he's living bring back that guy from the
deleted scene that they based the
terminators on from Terminator 3 that's
a easter egg it's the one way it
connects to with the voice and
everything and I like the tone of this
trailer it seems to have a little bit
more of that harrowing vibe it looks
very pretty this movie but the music
seems to have that apocalyptic tone to
it that like dark foreboding you know
yeah very yeah
which feels more like the Terminator to
that I remember I'm not a hundred
percent sold on it you know yeah I I
feel like feel like I'm kind of meeting
people in the middle at this play
because I've been out there defending
this movie before anyone saw you footage
your wife like that for this even
premiered I had so much like high hopes
for it and then there are people who've
just daughter or Terminator movie is
stupid and and then I think there are
people who felt that way we're gonna see
this children go oh wait nevermind this
looks really cool and then someone like
me who's like oversold myself is like
okay now I'm a little bit about a
hundred percent sold on everything right
now right now III do want to see more
but I mean from listening to a giant-ass
interview watching the footage here it's
pretty much it seems like it's gonna
deliver what I'm expecting from it and
what I want yeah and they really care to
make some characters that you'll be
heavily invested in before there's like
all these crazy acts
sequences and I I get divided that I
probably will get my [ __ ] up in a couple
of yeah everything sounds good to me so
far like everybody involved and yeah I
mean this is ostensibly just a tease of
the tone and some of the action
set-pieces so yeah I'm gonna kind of
reserve judgement or any like further
speculation judgement there until we get
another you know fuller on trailer or
something like that but but generally
speaking I'm cautiously optimistic guys
you can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification Bell tell us
what you think of this dark fate trailer
if you like this video hit the like
button and also make sure to follow us
on the starless app see you guys